so episode number what is it 132 or 131
135 135 i am behind
about four whole episodes
we've got the one we gotta get a cia guy
15 year former cia
uh mike baker here with us mike how you
doing man i'm doing well thanks very
much yeah we we did a zoom interview
during covet but we have done a facebook
facebook it's great to have you here and
thank you yeah and uh i got word you
were here early five o'clock looking
working on the wire so i don't know what
you were working on you know you were
optimistic yeah it was not easy getting
into your lair here by the way this is
actually a bank vault it is a bank it's
fair it's fully a bank vault yeah and we
are hoping to
get some legit information out of you
with all the mess that's going on in the
world we lock that door we're not
letting you know
you tell us exactly what's going on
well we're here for a long time then
it's our version of level one
security let me ask you this though let
me ask you this you know today i'm
driving i'm like okay we've had a lot of
former cia guys on we had you know uh
what do you call it uh
uh jack barskian a few days ago was a
couple weeks ago jack barsky kgb we've
had matt zeller matt zeller we've had a
lot of different people on mckinley
we've had a few people right
and i sit down and i'm thinking
what is the policy on what you can share
as a former cia because you know yeah
the movie argo you know the movie yeah
oh we can't you release these stories
for 30 years and this whole thing they
use the movie from canada to go in and
take these people out what a great thing
that they did
what can't like are there stuff that you
really you know that you went through
that you can't ever talk about is that
the code oh sure yeah i mean look you've
signed secrecy agreements and those
secret agreements don't expire you know
even if you retire or leave i didn't
retire i
wasn't old enough but i'd been there for
going on two decades and and
when it came time to leave as an example
um and i left for fairly pedestrian
reasons i was raising a daughter um so i
was i was a single dad and and needed to
be home because as it turns out that's
that's one of those things that makes
you a good parent if you're home
with your young children so so i thought
i got to do something to stay home so i
talked to my folks in the operations
directorate and they couldn't have been
better to me i said well look i'm going
to leave
i guess i'm you know going to try to
start a business
and
hey they questioned that in terms of
whether i had any skills that would
transfer into business and um
but they said okay fine you know you
let's make it so that you can leave and
at least say where you were meaning at
the the agency the outfit and
that was a really that was a really
generous thing for them to do but the
agreement is that i have a
responsibility that i don't talk about
sources and methods i don't get into
specifics but it allowed me to come out
and at least not say that i was an
import export guy you know for the past
going on 20 years and and that helped
then build a business as it turns out
and um
particularly where i am i'm in the
global intelligence and security
industry right so
there was a direct relationship to it if
i had come out and said well i was uh in
business or i was uh in government
somehow it wouldn't have had much impact
so the agency was very good to me in
that regard and therefore i'm very tight
on what you can and can't say it makes
sense not is is it is it a
uh is it a competitive uh thing between
fbi and cia or no like is it like we're
better than you we're better it's more
like we work together like firefighters
versus cops where they play the baseball
game so
it's not even competitive because we're
so much better oh no no no no no there
you go that's that's [ __ ] i'm not no
i i i'm not going to say that like i
know a lot of guys uh even though you're
the bureau and i i think very highly of
them
they are great but there was um
particularly pre-911 there was a there
was tension between the bureau and the
agency and
the bureau started putting their people
out in the field um overseas to take on
counterterrorism uh
activity and that's always been sort of
the purview of of my outfit and so
that created some tension and and just
some confusion what are you guys doing
out here what's what's your objective
and why are you here and taking up our
space and and so
that created some um some
liaison problems in terms of sharing of
intelligence
and
you know so you you go in as an example
if you were operating somewhere and you
were engaged in a counter-terrorist
operation and the bureau uh came in and
they were doing some
you know activity and element you always
had this feeling like we weren't really
being completely square with each other
so we weren't really sharing uh you know
completely got it and and then why
though is it like who solves the mystery
and who saw is that kind of what it is
yeah you know it's it was kind of you
know you're pissing on my turf right and
so how about you not it's
territorial competitive
it was but now it's i will say this much
it is it is immensely improved um the
the liaison between the organizations is
is so much better now than it was again
15 10 years ago collaborative
relationships
it's much better because you know in
part 9 11 forced that i mean you know
you suddenly realize look we there were
there were gaps there that did you know
we we probably could have avoided if we
but it's a human endeavor right it's
always going to there's always going to
be an element of risk you're never going
to minimize it down to zero question for
you so you know the the we had oliver
stone on last week and uh so i went on a
binge watching of all these jfk
assassination documentaries i've already
interviewed way too many people on that
topic but just something i'm curious
about
how jfk wanted to get rid of the cia i'm
sure you've read the story somewhere
which one of these organizations can
america do without so i'll give you the
list and you tell me so and i hope
you're not going to be politically
correct just to give a safe answer you
got cia you got fbi you got pd you got
dea you got the irs you got oh
which one of these guys can we go
without and it would probably make
america a better place can we put
congress on the list yeah wait i was
gonna say can we put uh yeah could we
play you didn't you just pull up rick
perry and forget the names that you're
gonna ask
oops
we gotta get rid of these three agencies
i can only name two though i apologize
the department of uh what um education
yeah you know what the ones that you
mentioned the you know the cia the the
bureau um dea
um
you know
i would i would argue you can't get rid
of any of those right there so there's a
real reason why those exist now you know
at times the bureaucracies get too big
you know
yeah fine but um you know it's like when
people say we got to get rid of you know
customs and you know border patrol uh or
ice get rid of these
it's a simplistic way of you know
looking at it and when it comes from a
politician it's they're just blowing
smoke up people's ass to you know score
a point you know right because it's
popular to say it so
um irs
yeah you know do we need it to to
enhance the size of the irs i don't
think so are taxes a good thing in if
they're used properly sure yeah so
you know i'm probably not the best
person to talk about this but definitely
don't get rid of the cia right it is it
is a [ __ ] up world out there and you
need
uh i'll say a political you need an
apolitical intelligence service right is
the cia a political these days yeah i
mean i would again it's it's
you know
it it it gets uh it it's had a it had a
beating uh about the same time that the
bureau was taking a beating you know and
um
but
my experience that's all i can talk to
i was in the operations side of things
and um you know i'd spent my whole time
overseas so
i never saw it as a political
organization right we i never had
political conversations with any of the
guys that i was working with right we'd
sit in a safe house for three weeks
waiting for something to pop we didn't
sit there talking politics it just
wasn't it wasn't something you did and
when i'd come back and walk the
corridors in in the main building
there were political discussions so you
never had that feeling that that that's
how that build and you don't want that
i've seen countries where there's a
change in government and they just they
sh [ __ ] can everybody bring in an entire
new intel service that's politically you
know bound to whatever administrations
come in that is a disaster that you
definitely don't want
tom what do you think
what do you think out of those uh you
know he even put ice in there so let's
throw ice in there as well which one of
those do you think we can go without
well i've always thought and i still
think that department homeland security
is there at you know airports and the
border and most most air travel is like
cross state lines so why wouldn't
homeland security be part of fbi fbi
covers across state lines you know law
enforcement conflict in this nation has
been sort of a staple right where the
local police are working on a case
whoops it's a lot of money across state
lines fbi excuse me step back that's
ours right so this conflicts have
happened i've always thought that the
border patrol and homeland security are
redundant since homeland security was
created after 9 11 i said well what does
the border patrol do and if it's if it's
borders and interstate things why
wouldn't the fbi have that and why did
we create
this these notions so that's my thinking
i think there's redundancy in some of it
but i agree that the fbi is an entity
and the cia entity and the nsa is an
entity i would never screw with either
one of those three okay how about atf i
mean alcohol yeah tobacco i was just
going to ask that question
i'm a big fan of all of them
i know i wasn't sure what the question
was right well yeah in texas it's like
oh i like alcohol tobacco i like
firearms that's a question
anyway in texas atf is a convenience
store not a federal bureau
the interview you did the debates the
great debates you you debated whether we
need
a war on drugs or whether we've won the
war on drugs do you have a strong
opinion of who won that argument or were
your thoughts on it yeah atf i mean but
atf is a 1.4 billion dollar budget 5082
employees including
2653 special agents
760 industry operation investigators
okay
what are we doing alcohol tobacco
firearms like what do what do we so for
me you know anytime like in in the world
of business when you go at the end of
the year you look at your expenses and
budget what do you look at you look at
it and you say uh
why are we spending money for this what
are we doing with this so rather than
constantly adding i think we're not
spending enough time thinking about what
we can take away
and give that responsibility to one of
these other departments that can
probably do the job we don't need to
have another constantly come up with the
different depart maybe i'm wrong
but that's not the nature of government
nato government is not you know as a as
an animal is not to shrink itself um and
uh so
once once budgets get set um you know
trying to it's like every every year uh
in the agency
towards the end of the calendar year
you'd get this this uh note or somebody
would say something from senior
management about like what do you guys
need right what do you need do you need
more gear do you need more you know and
because we got to spend the money yeah
money's in the budget if we don't spend
it now then our next budget might be
smaller because they're going to look
and go well you guys didn't need that so
we'll reallocate those resources but i
do agree you know the the after 9 11
when they created uh homeland security
but more importantly when they created
dni um
that was something probably could be
looked at right to to shrink that
because i think they did put a lot of
redundancy in there it was just layers
of bureaucracy to combine all the
various members of the intel community
and and law enforcement and i think
that's never really functioned the way
that it should plus also i'm not a big
fan of having a dni instead of having
the cia director with a seat at the
table and that's what kind of what they
did they pushed the cia director out
said oh the dni is going to be the guy
and that's a little too political for me
could and by the way tyler go ahead and
ask you a great question tyler i was
just going to say you're talking about
the the budget's always growing that's
not how bureaucracy works the government
is the single largest employer in the
country how many like i love the
libertarian perspective of small
government so how many of these
organizations can we privatize can we
privatize the fbi can we privatize the
cia we privatize
what have you like does it have to be a
government organization because you can
make the claim that uh if you privatize
one of these organizations it will
become biased or what have you but
you're seeing the same thing now with
all the government wouldn't it benefit
to privatize
i'm asking as a capitalist but i'm
asking you what's the benefit if we
privatize well it seems to me that the
private sector can
run infinitely better
anything operation-wise
you're saying they're gonna be more
efficient because you've got money
profit loss correct i think i think it
could be better to the taxpayer let me
ask you how do you operate better how do
you think media sells prints
it's eric prince
is that
from blackwell how do you think he's
portrayed as i think a lot of people
despise him i mean we have them coming
on the podcast i think in two weeks or
three weeks right yeah how is he he's
he's sold as a what he's not a warmonger
yeah so so you know that's the part as
well and then say the wrong guy any you
know i don't know i don't know so who's
this guy this abidely likely to nominate
the new atf head of uh after first one
was pulled eight say the president is
committed to filing the post on original
vacant for david shipman's nomination
failed to get needed support in the
senate do you know when atf got started
do you know when atf got started 1961.
so in 1961 atf so when 1961 atf got
started was alcohol legal
yes okay was tobacco legal of course
okay was uh
firearms legal yes so what what like
what is your job your job is who was the
president that was that jfk at that
point 61.
one uh i would say yeah yeah
i'm foggy in this but remember one of
the
areas of non-violent uh crime by
organized crime was the old pink tax
sticker that used to be on top of all
the liquor bottles and they would print
all these things in the bahamas or in
the caribbean and these tax stickers
were then put on
on this and as i recall it was treasury
department before atf that actually
presided over that with even hoover
saying wait a minute this is organized
crime what are you guys doing here oh do
you think it's do you think it's weird
you got that information in your head
do you think that's that's an
interesting i'm fine welcome to the
world of the biz doc mike baker it's a
lot of information because that's a lot
of information in your head and i'm very
impressed my head is my brain is like
new york city oh okay
by the way he just figured you out in 10
minutes we call him the walking
wikipedia this guy is always really
getting involved i thought that was a
very real thing it's like where the fbi
was out there hey we're trying to bust
bootleggers over here what are you doing
here well these are tax stickers and
this belongs to the american people this
little pink thing and there were
actually non-violent criminals that were
out there printing on the tax side but
that weren't whacking each other like
they were during prohibition
and all of a sudden we now haven't guess
what atf we'll make a new division make
a new department but
if i could jump over to that question
about privatizing certain things uh
look we went in uh during the first what
do we call it incursion into iraq
um
i had uh i was i was out at that point
but we put a bunch of guys we put a
bunch of guys into uh into iraq um at
the behest of some uh clients that we
had that were
going to be doing infrastructure work
out there in iraq you know they already
knew it you know and and so
so we had been doing some things for
them elsewhere and they said look from a
security perspective you know can you
help us out and so
we started putting people in there um
really at the same time or just slightly
ahead of when the troops went into iraq
and
we're private business right so we start
building up an operation out there and
this is early days this is before
blackwater became a household name and
and and
um so we watched
that sort of that private contractor
private security industry build in iraq
over a few years and
um
it was it's a bit of a [ __ ] show because
it's a private business and so we saw
people looking and going i could make
money doing that so you had you know a
large number of moocs with no experience
thinking i'm going to start a security
company and they were banging around
washington dc where we had an office and
we'd come back i'd come back and say oh
could you meet with these guys they want
to you know talk to you about you know
lobbyists
well these these were guys that were
pseudo lobbyists or they were just they
were just guys hanging around washington
and thinking i'll bet i could get a
contract somewhere and this is a good
business so you started getting all
these companies showing up and i
remember talking to some of these
companies and you know whether they're
british or american whatever and
and look you don't have an endless
supply of trained people with sufficient
experience to operate in a hostile
environment like that
whether it's providing security or
gathering intelligence or whatever so
that bar kept lowering and i'd i'd talk
to somebody and they'd say yeah i was um
sbs you know out of the british you know
teams and you think no you're not you
know because we've got the former
commander you know working with us and
he's never heard of you and
you you this would happen time and time
again so eventually people were hiring
just you know people with no experience
no business being out there and that's
when [ __ ] started to happen and so then
what happened when that
yeah kerfuffle started was that the
government got involved and said look
we've got to you know we've got to
regulate this we've got to come up and
so there was this effort with the
private businesses now starting to see
wait a minute we're our business is
being threatened because now the
government's looking at it you know
maybe the government's going to step in
and start you know regulating this so we
started meeting as private contracting
companies saying we've got to form an
association here set some standards
right and
well you're doing that because you're
trying to protect your business you're
not necessarily doing it because you
know none of these guys really cared
about that but they were doing it so
they wouldn't lose their contracts so so
some of the government i guess my point
being government involvement in there
was actually an important part of it
right because it helped the regulation
the regulation um the
you know setting some standards getting
some of the idiots out of it uh so i
you know again i'm conflicted because i
can see both sides so after after they
came in and and you guys set the
standards how did it work out in
comparison um you know what it it worked
out better because there was more
policing of
of uh protocols of hiring of
requirements there was more you know
so i i don't know it's it's uh it was
one of those things i just wanted to
raise the point i'm you know i don't
want to disappear down that route
companies like that like if i'm
halliburton and i find out that my
security team was maybe substandard not
as good as they pitched me in the
powerpoint deck and i'm hiring them to
protect basically u.s civilians who have
agreed to go into a hostile theater and
work on a an electric power grid project
right right so now i'm a little bit
concerned by that and this kind of
didn't that help the companies weren't
they appreciative that now they have
some sort of reliance and standards
right that my civilians that are over
there working on a damn more kind of it
was a lot of infrastructure yeah there
was no and that's that's a good point
and they did appreciate it and it was it
was beneficial to them um
you would like to have thought that they
would have been you know look we were
the companies we worked with they were
very clear about we'd expect
you know the following uh in terms of
standards and and you know it but i
guess you know my point being is that
if you leave it up to private business
it may not there's always that statement
oh private businesses how to run things
right they're going to be more efficient
than government
yeah
you know but you there is a place for
government at times or it goes the other
way right because whacking hut has
actually hired remember whack and hut
hired to do the private prisons in the
u.s and they've actually hired their own
lobbyists because they like tougher
criminal laws because it makes an influx
of prisoners that need a place to sleep
which means you build another prison
yeah so so for private business to uh to
benefit from wars that concerns me
because you're you know you know what
i'm saying that concerns me part of me
is the military industry totally exactly
i was going to go there and that's but
but you know somebody can you increase
tyler's audio as well like ten percent
uh you know but but for me so then the
other side of it if i'm being a devil's
advocate to myself is it's gonna happen
anyways because the guy on the inside
that's on the government hey you you do
this i'm gonna give you this hey lobby
is coming in i think the problem here
for that to work out
is if you eliminated lobbyists a lot of
things would be more honest
and transparent because these guys that
are making 10 20 million a year a
lobbyist is making it's one of the
highest paying jobs in america by the
way being a lobbyist pays very well by
the way just just out of curiosity
you know these uh uh
conspiracies you read about okay and you
know i don't know if you're into
conspiracies or not a lot of people are
as a ci agent i'm sure you're not but uh
you know some of these conspiracies like
who who are some of the names that are
dropped that
world leaders that were you know working
for the cia because you know on the mob
you'll read this boss was working
closely with the fbi and nobody knew
about it for 15 years
he was this and he was dropping all the
information and i'm not even talking
about like a joe piston
you know who was actually working for
the fbi that went in for five years and
10 months i'm talking about like
actual world leaders that was donnie
brasco was it yeah i'm not talking
donnie branson i'm talking about guys
that were world leaders who some say
the cia had them in their pockets and
they were giving them information who
were some of the names yeah you know
what um
well vladimir putin um
he'd be one of them no i'm kidding
i'm just kidding everybody's wide open
on the table
yeah
he's secretly going to destroy that was
good i got to give it to you that was
really good
mike's got a little bit of acting you
know
comedy yeah um
you know it's it's
there's been
that's a really good question because in
turn in terms of world leaders normally
the question is like you know were there
celebrities were there you know people
that that had worked because they were
in the public eye but they could travel
everywhere and had access you know from
a world leader perspective that's not
really
that's not a target when you're talking
about a collection target if you're
looking to recruit uh access
to a country
your your first
landing spot is not the the leader right
i mean maybe there's relationships that
exist
um
as that person was coming up through the
ranks or whatever and eventually became
a leader and so you're going to you're
going to want to know what that's all
about you want to know whether you've
got anybody who went to school with them
or did whatever and that's that could
provide you with some insight but really
you're looking for
people who have actionable intelligence
uh at sort of a granular level so i you
know i would rather have rather than the
world leader sure it'd be nice to have
them in their pocket but um
you know you want that the guy who's
running a desk you know for a priority
target in some other intel service
overseas right i mean you're looking
that's what that's what you're looking
to do or you're looking for the the
deputy assistant uh foreign minister
right who's got terrific access but is
he's right there in decision making you
know
points
that's the sort of thing or you know
what you want the uh the housekeeper you
know for the uh for the world leader um
proximity but number one is what you're
saying how do you how do you recruit
what's the method of recruiting folks
like that
uh you know it's it's usually not
ideology right um it's usually a little
bit more based than that um so you're
talking you know possibly money maybe
you're talking about
you know you you
bump across some guy that's it's working
and your indications are maybe their gru
for instance or they're you know they're
fsb or whatever and you think uh that'd
be a good target and so you know maybe
you find out they got a couple of young
kids um and that's their i don't say
their weak link but that's really what
drives them you know and that a lot of
times that's what it is maybe their
kid's sick maybe they need some medical
attention right there's some assistance
and that's simple yeah
it could be that simple um
it could be that oftentimes it not often
but another scenario is that they're
just not getting enough hugs from their
home service right or from wherever
they're
they're not feeling the love they feel
like they're disrespected nobody's
listening to me i'm too smart for this
place and so now suddenly you're
providing an outlet for them and now
they feel important because now they're
getting that information to somebody
right and and it sounds odd right it
sounds like who's gonna [ __ ] gonna
betray their country and their family
and their government
but
you know that sometimes can be a very
powerful thing right and that's
unfortunately in the counterintelligence
world when we talk about people like
hanson right and jim nicholson or some
of these guys headley howard that's
pretty much what it was they just didn't
feel like they were respected they were
too smart for their own place when the
cia sets their sights on somebody and
says we want to get this target i assume
that's how it works like this is the
person we want
it's driven by it's driven by tasking so
it's driven by like okay we we need to
know
exactly to the degree we can what the
you know chinese military is spending
their money on you know in the next you
know
two years or three years are they
dumping all their money into hypersonics
or whatever so yeah you know be nice to
get somebody in the pla or whatever and
so it's driven by the tasking and then
you start looking at who's got that
who's got access to that information and
who might be minded to talk to you who
could you actually access who could you
get to
so there's a process that you go through
and to be fair most intel services go
through the same process because it's a
human thing and when they get
this target or this mission
how hard is it for that person to say no
meaning how much do you squeeze this
person to say
i'm not saying yeah
i mean i got to imagine if you set your
sights on somebody and that's your
target you're not going to take no for
an answer no no
it's i see what you say but it doesn't
work that way because you you never want
to coerce somebody into this right you
don't want to because that's a that's a
bad route it's it's like with blackmail
people always think uh you're gonna you
know you're gonna you know hook them
because they they've compromised
themselves well
maybe but then this is somewhat nuanced
if someone compromises itself they do go
out there and they do something that
they as if say they're an intel uh
you know officer for some foreign
country that's a target for us
uh if they compromise themselves they do
something they shouldn't have done
you're not necessarily using that right
as as the hook what you're doing is
you're saying okay there's a weakness
there right there's a
they've that's that's the weakness now
we're going to build around that right
because
you know hooking somebody up by
blackmail or or strong-arming them
then it just it just doesn't work their
heart needs to be in it essentially well
they need to feel that they're they're
doing the right thing right and they're
doing it for the right reason even if
they're complete you know [ __ ] and
you know and
you know it's just
why'd you look at tom when you said that
he doesn't appreciate that there we go
even if they're a complete [ __ ] i
mean so
yeah i mean there you go there's a
reason we're opposite that
by the way so
a question about you know the most
shocking declassified secrets in u.s
history right you got you got this uh
uh uh where you know going into files
and pulling out the top juiciest most
interesting government secrets all of
them have been
declassified meaning governments in
question have
uh released documents confirming the
truth fyi folks season two of black
files declassified airing is it
wednesday nine p.m eastern standard time
on science channel and discovery plus
with mike baker you can find season one
of black files the classified is
available on amazon prime i believe a
link is in the description of the
podcast we'll put it below
uh for some of you guys and then maybe
at the end we'll show preview
uh of that so you'll be on the first to
see it yeah so here's here's ten of them
we have okay the u.s relationship with
khomeini okay
declassified records have revealed that
ayatollah khomeini a cleric who would
later emerge as the driving force in
islamic fundamentalism was much closer
to the american government than
previously thought romania has sought to
negotiate with the kennedy and carter
administration in order to ease
his takeover of iran despite his public
anti-american rhetoric going as far as
calling america the great satan i was
there for 10 years when he was ruling
six weeks after he died we left iran and
we went to germany at a refugee camp so
i watch everything that they were
talking about on tv i was old enough to
remember some of this stuff and the
great satan i mean forget about that
they used to say death upon america look
outside the window and not see ten
thousand men march flagellating their
backs this is not just like in movies
this is stuff that you actually saw as a
kid so how much credibility is there if
romani was
with the cia i mean
he's
what do you know about this story he
wasn't with the cia but there was
you know there were efforts to try to
because part of what they were doing is
trying to assess who who the hell he is
and you know what his chances are of of
taking over what his plans and
intentions would be so there was there
was contact right so you end up getting
contact reports written constantly you
know by you know i had a chance to talk
to him or somebody meets with him
maybe from state department and then you
you sit down and you talk with that
person you say okay what okay what what
do you guys talk about what what the
hell is going on and so you build up a
file the file doesn't mean that the
person's working for the government i
mean you go down to the archives and
basements of the the agency
and so it sounds like we've got like a
basement i'd like to go to the basement
of the agency
yeah it's a fault it's much like this
and so uh so you uh you you know there's
just
file after file of of uh full of contact
reports where you're assessing people
and some of them you know like this
would it would think like that's insane
there's no way that this guy's gonna
they're not really it's not like they
think we're gonna target him and recruit
him what they're thinking is we gotta
you know we gotta understand him we
gotta know what the world looks like
around him maybe we're gonna identify
somebody who's in his orbit that we
could recruit so there's a lot of
reasons why you would do this but
you know it's it's it's very common now
pat
this is literally your life based on
your childhood
would the cia have motivation to want to
get the shah out of yours okay of course
explain that for those of you here can
you go pull up this story on the
guardian just
google khomeini
it's very easy name to spell romani
k-h-o
best of luck i look that if your job
depends on the whole main spelling bee
there you go that one right there so
make that bigger u.s had extensive
contact with the ayatollah that's a
guardian story by the way so with
ayatollah khamenei before your
revolution documents seen by the bbc
suggests carter administration paved the
way for khomeini to return to iran by
holding the army back from launching a
military
he was in paris for like 12 to 15 years
the bbc reporting suggests that the card
administration took care of khamenei's
pledges and in effect paved the way for
his return to iran the bbc persian
service obtained a draft message
washington had prepared as a response to
romanian welcome the the ayatollah the
corporation also published a previously
released but unnoticed declassified 1980
ci analysis titled islam in iran which
shows khomeini's initial attempts to
reach u.s
to the uh reach out to the us data back
to 1963 16 years before the revolution
the bbc revolution had created a
reports have created a huge role in iran
if true they would undermine the myth
that romani staunchly resisted any
direct links with the us which remained
taboo
for three decades until the recent
nuclear negotiations go down to look at
the note go down to look at the note
here let me read above it what it says
about it
right there other iranian politicians
have also questioned the bbc's
revelations including ibrahim yazdi
khomeini spokesman and adviser of the
time of the revolution saeed hajarian a
former former reformist refu
figure in november 1963 romani uh uh
sent a message to united states
government through hajj mirza khalil
kamari a professor of the technological
faculty of tehran university and an
iranian politician close to opposition
as religious groups romanians explained
that he was not opposed to american
interests in iran interesting on the
contrary he thought the american
presence was necessary as a
counterbalance to soviet and possibly
british influence khamenei also
explained his belief in the close
cooperation between islam and other
world religions particularly christian
by the way so you asked the question
what the motivation would be there's a
doctrine
there's a documentary that they did on
the show
uh fantastic documentary that it's about
oil so they had a 25-year contract iran
did that was coming up in 1979 this was
signed in 1954 matter of fact if you
look it up
uh and you type in 1954
oil iran do me a favor can you type in
1954 oil iran
um
you'll see it it's called the cons
consortium agreement of 1954
okay that was expiring by 1979
okay and this was with
us british
i think it's germans french
and these guys had a meeting in 76 77
these four world leaders had a meeting i
think in south or central america
to talk about what we need to do to get
rid of the shot because by 1979 when the
25 years came up he was going to
renegotiate the contract increase the
comp and make more money and they said
this is not good for us we got to get
rid of this guy because he's becoming
too strong and obviously so you're
saying he's specifically an oil play oh
listen if i'm if i'm everything is
speculation you have to know this is you
know
not nothing we know especially what's
going on right now with ukraine russia
we have no clue 100 percent what
everything is going on but my
speculation based on
what i've researched 80 percent of it
was caused because they did not want one
man
to have as much power as he had anything
to get rid of them is what they needed
and then that's what well i guess
i may be wrong so what was the date of
the commanding contact pat what was it
63 november of 63 yeah yeah you know
what that letter started with dear
lyndon congratulations on the new job
sorry to hear about your boss i
understand you feel different about
world political affairs wow
yeah right after november
well we don't know because we need to
know if that is
uh uh what the date is on that but
you're right i really like to know when
that date is because it's the 22nd
there's that encyclopedia
but there's also i mean you know part of
this is also that the development of the
individual right so you look at 63 then
you look down the road you look at the
mid 70s how how many changed you know
and how he was developing his his belief
system and and also he was looking in
terms of you know how to control and how
to maintain power and what's that going
to look like so
you know you see these and i guess i go
back to the same thing
you would see
you know this with other
whether it's castro or anyone else
that's part of what the cia
is doing right they're they're assessing
their understanding that they're looking
at potential lines of communication
they're looking and
but i do think it's it's fascinating the
oil uh
play because i mean that you know you
look at the history of britain uh of the
uk and in iran and
yeah the whole thing is is based on oil
pat let me ask you before we move on
yeah is it fair to say they got this
wrong meaning whatever hand they had in
this
didn't work out well for the world or
iran but depends on who you ask if you
ask the industrial military complex no
there was a war that made a lot of money
with iraq if you ask how about not them
the rest of the world
yeah because this led to
them releasing 3 000 political prisoners
that uh the shah had and a part of it
was the start of
uh you know osama bin laden and isis and
all that other stuff so he had those
guys he deshawn was concerned about a
couple different parties the extremists
the
uh the you know hezbollah's the isis and
then the other side he was very paranoid
about was today the two-day party the
two-day party was the aoc the communist
party is what it was like think about
far left and far right so mossadegg was
like a socialist bernie sanders so he
was worried about the communists and he
was worried about
the isis so when this happened they
released 911 indirectly as a byproduct
of having them being released while the
shah's like because you know how people
always bash savage
you know
horrible people okay kgb [ __ ] once a
kgb forever kgb well what the hell is
cia
like
but the way we see
kgb and savage is the way iran and
russia sees
cia and mi6 right you know but the way
we say mi6 and cia we kind of said oh
it's nice people to see anybody so
meaning there is patriots
by the way i mean you know i'm maybe
born in iran but i'm made you know i'm
made in iran but i'm you know born in
iran
i'm about america but at the same time
you know you have to keep in mind that
you know
everybody's buying into some kind of
propaganda so somebody may say right now
hey who gives a [ __ ] about the story i
don't care about iran i don't care about
comedy i don't care about this stuff
what does this have to do with today
here's the point
i don't want to wait
60 years
59 years whatever it is i don't want to
even from 1980 i don't want to wait 41
years to find out what the hell is going
on with ukraine and russia
i don't know of it either i want to know
what's the cause of covet i want to know
what's going on with ukraine and russia
i want to know what the hell this fauchy
guy was all about i want to know why he
kept saying the same [ __ ] all over again
i want to know what is going on today so
to the average average person
charlemagne irrelevant but a price was
paid worldwide for a bad decision and
everybody directly or indirectly whether
you know it or not you were affected by
it you know mike you brought up
something i want to get to pat's
question right there so you talked about
the development of khomeini so obviously
the agency and without going into
details you can't you're tracking
the intellectual change the evolution of
thought and the evolution of aggression
i mean you got people like manuel
noriega from the perfect little pond to
the pain in the ass and when he became a
pain in the ass we went down there and
stuck him in a florida prison right yeah
and so you see that there's a lot talk
today in the ukraine that said that
people looking at putin and these are
people that are on cnn msnbc fox
everywhere and they're saying
it really looks in the last five years
there's been a change in him and he's a
little off rails
are you seeing that
no i don't think he's i mean yeah i've
heard that maybe there's been
assessments you know
yeah
look
that but putin's a good example of this
and it's it's
what we're talking about is
yeah the big question right now is the
intel point here that everyone's trying
to collect on is what's his plans and
intentions right so that's saying we're
going to get inside this guy's head what
do you have to do to do that there's a
there's a [ __ ] ton of assessment that
goes on you're looking for again points
of access you're looking for recruitment
of targets that might be able to tell
you what the hell is going on uh with
putin the honest guy's truth is nobody
really knows except for putin at this
point you know it's a heavy lift to to
collect on that target so
you know i i i'm not
i'm not surprised by this i think the
the idea that there was uh
contact between romini and and the the
u.s government to me makes perfect sense
because that's what we you see that in
other locations countries throughout
history as well they're you know they're
looking to build up their power base
they're looking you know for a line of
communication and and yeah the the
agency or or any intel service is out
there trying to understand what the
hell's going on because they're that's
what they're told to do but uh
yeah i forgot my late training you know
i don't tell you what the evolution of
you know
all my senses
but you know what i will say here's what
i will say
i trust my enemies more than my allies
let me say why
i trust my enemies more than my allies
because every morning my enemies wake up
at least they're honest they want to do
whatever they can to put me out of
business
my allies i don't necessarily fully know
their incentives and their motives i 100
know the incentive the motives of my
enemy i know the enemy wants to do
whatever they can to have an upper edge
over me i'm naive if i don't believe
that okay
but with your allies you don't
necessarily know what is their next 10
moves maybe you're move number three but
you're dispen you know you're
what's the word dispense you're you can
be
dispensed
in move number eight and you're like oh
he's acting like an ally but what is
really is mode of being an ally versus
the enemy's like look i want to kill you
it's that simple i want to put you out
of business
i trust
that russians motives
are more honest than anybody else's
that's sitting there saying oh my gosh
iran defending ukraine yeah yeah i don't
trust what the hell iran is doing saying
stuff about ukraine i don't trust that i
trust the fact that putin's saying
that's our land
we're going to take it here's what we're
doing
not in a positive trust there's a trust
of a very
honest trusted enemy so for me when i'm
sitting here thinking
you know his playbook you don't like the
playbook but you know the playbook
yeah i i i know fully
this is a true believer we're dealing
with that knows what he wants and is
going after it well he's been he's been
very consistent so to answer your
question people think is he going off
the rails well no he's consistent in his
moves whether it's
you know what he did in crimea what he
did in chechnya what he you know didn't
abkhazia what he didn't sell i mean it's
it it's the same thing that he's been
doing and he's been very clear to your
point he's been very honest about you
know the fall of the soviet union was
the greatest tragedy of the 20th century
and he believes that and he said it and
repeatedly and and his intent has always
been to recreate a sphere of influence
so he is being very honest about this so
i think when people say oh my god we
can't understand what he's doing
that's what he does
because i feel assembling what he views
as mother russia i fully agree with what
you're saying is that you 100 trust your
enemies because you know exactly what
their motivation is yeah whereas your
allies you might not be sure what is
down the line like i think of the movies
like even in batman
um or the dark knight or even in like
the movies like the town you're robbing
a bank together boom joker is exactly
but as soon as you get well he knows
that the cops or the batman is gonna
come after him and that's his enemy but
as soon as they get the money boom he
kills a couple of his guys boom he keeps
all the money so the next question here
is we know putin's the enemy right i
mean that's fair to say
but the next question is our ally here
is this guy's zilinski what do we truly
know about him what is he really our
ally does he what does he want from the
world that's i think the big question
here yeah this degree is that
there's degrees of from good and bad
right i mean it's like
the agency
one thing you you learn very quickly is
it's nothing's black and white and yet
you know the world wants to frame
everything that way right so now the
social media story is oh my god you know
the the ukraine well look ukraine had a
lot of problems right corruption being
you know up the top of the list so and
there's a very difficult history there
in with ukraine and so
we just have to be aware of that it
doesn't change the fact that putin's an
[ __ ] and
i'll look over time again
and uh if it's officially written it's
official yeah you have a cia guy that
thinks you're an [ __ ] tom
that's just what the file tells me and
so i think uh
i'm sorry thank you very much so i'll
see you next week guys
tom ellsworth goes missing it hasn't
seen her in 60 to 90 days
but
the you know i guess the point being is
that
with zielinski um
yeah you you just have to be pragmatic
about all this and and the one thing i
do worry about is is how simple
everything gets framed right and how
quickly the news story you know becomes
this three-minute bite of of everything
and
yeah if you look at what we're doing
right now um in terms of i mean to bring
iran by back into it if you look at the
negotiations
that we're having with iran and
utilizing russia
now
right to in part to try to you know
develop an alternative
supply line for oil
and
in part and this is where i'm very
cynical it's because you know the
current administration here in the u.s
realizes we can't suffer these [ __ ]
gas prices for very long because the
midterm elections are coming up
and so we got to do something so for
political reasons maybe i'm being
cynical you know they're pushing forward
on this negotiation because they damn it
we got to get these sanctions off so we
can let the iranian oil flow so we can
keep prices down so we don't get our
asses kicked in the election so okay so
so so now here's what oliver stone said
the other day when the conversation came
about what's going on with and i want to
get your reaction on this see if you
could put them on like uh you're going
to do 2.0 don't do that put two 1.5 yeah
is this about what he said with the
proxy is this is this that clip title
okay go ahead play this clip
by the way very organized i think the
cia plays another role there because
cia's been involved with ukrainian nazis
since world war ii we got a lot of them
out to our country on the rat lines and
we came back after world war ii and 48
there was a an operation by the cia to
drop these people into ukraine to make
trouble to start uh troubles for uh
russia
it's an old story it's not new you know
this is but i don't think a lot of
people know it well it's a fact in fact
the guy i worked with on jfk fletcher
proudly was a colonel who was in world
war ii and air force and he was one of
those guys who supplies these these uh
uh infiltration infiltrators to the
ukraine with weapons and with flights
and you have to drop them and so forth
and so on it's a lot of hardware all
these guys were picked up by the way
that's what's amazing
it's like with castro whenever we go up
against castro he seems to find out the
people we send in uh secretly it's an
interesting side effect but the russians
picked up the russian ukraine picked up
these people but we tried to is this
what he talks about is this where he
talks about his drink is going oh i'm
doing this
is this where he talks about the part i
want you to get is when he talks about
this is just a proxy
war between uh us's just using ukraine
is this the clip or no
you sure yeah
positive play for 20 more seconds let's
see because so far we've been waiting
so so so now if we watch tv today and we
turn it on you're seeing that
that is standing and he's you know
looking pretty strong and tough and he's
not you know reacting again the news is
telling us that russia has lost five to
six thousand soldiers uh in the last few
weeks which is more than what we lost in
iraq and you know the the two foreign
ministers had a conversation together
two three days ago it was an hour and
half conversation in turkey nothing uh
no advancements really made how
different is ukraine's story today
versus when you did the documentary how
much has changed because valencia is not
in your documentary when you did it
right so is it night and day different
story today are you making more progress
who was ukrainian
russian ukrainian and he did it i was an
interviewer and one of the producers so
these two films ukraine on fire and the
other one is called uh ukraine revealed
revealed goes into the present time
it's a very interesting documentary
about the opposition candidate victor
medvedev mega chuck victor medvedchuk
revealing ukraine that's it
robert perry was one of the great
journalists in our country it was the
most out of you
dude i'm telling you there's a clip that
it starts this guy's like we're watching
the entire episode with our friend here
just go to twitter go to my twitter
account let's show it from this angle
tyler just wanted us to see that for
whatever reason uh i was given this by
john
oh people under the bus all right so go
to go to media bus meet your media right
there okay click on the media side good
okay go up a little bit keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going keep going okay what does
that say that said no not john f kennedy
keep going keep going it's another clip
by him okay click on that one open it up
that's the truth the united states has
using ukraine as a proxy to put pressure
they don't us doesn't care about ukraine
they care about russia this is a chance
to destabilize russia remove the leader
regime change once again on a big on a
big way there's a big victory for them
if they can pull it off
and this was always the gold from the
beginning i i don't think there's any
concern about the ukrainian people
except as a sentimental thing in the
newspaper as well this person was killed
that person was killed but what about
the people were killed on the other side
they never mentioned them for five six
years no more than that eight years
those people were killed too families
were killed
um
you know it's possibly what you're
saying possibly so for me for me where
that goes to is
okay
carter used you know
uh
homeani to destabilize iran and shah
fell 79 it so happens to be the 25-year
expiration of oil exactly in 1979
what are they worried about trying to
get rid of this guy do you agree with
oliver stonehouse could there be any
truth to what he's saying with them
trying to get rid of putin
uh well look hey that'd be a happy
circumstance if that's the case i don't
think that was the that's not i wouldn't
draw a direct line like oliver stone is
doing but that's kind of his thing so um
but look is is it a proxy war
yeah of course it's a proxy war it's the
same thing as you know fighting in the
congo or you know years ago i mean it's
there's no
i don't think there's any doubt about
that right i mean we're dumping weapons
into ukraine you know we're helping the
people out um
it's against russia it's against putin
putin doesn't have our best interests at
heart so yeah this is a bizarre surreal
replay of the cold war
that we're marching ourselves into
but no i'm not i'm not drawing a direct
line saying you know at some point we
thought you know what we could do if we
could just foment unrest and get putin
so fired up that he moves in in a big
way i'll bet we could [ __ ] him over and
get it no i'm not i'm not buying that
and i think that's where he's going i
mean he's really you're not going there
no i'm not i'm not going there but i'm
not i'm also saying that yeah do
are we
backing
a country uh ukraine that's had you know
all sorts of history that we just need
to be aware of
but is that a better option than
standing by and watching you know putin
roll through and decide he's going to
rebuild the soviet union um
yeah i'm i'm on that you know side i
don't nobody wants to get the old thing
everybody's been saying i don't want to
get into shooting war with russia well
no [ __ ] right but
you know i i have no problem saying yeah
it's a it's a proxy war at this stage
and we're you know we're dangerously
close to you know entering a new version
of the cold war um
but yeah i'm i'm not a conspiracy guy to
go back to your original thing i you
know i
most things i've found over the years
and again it's just based on everyone
has to talk based on their own
experience it's a little bit simpler
than
you know a conspiracy theory would have
you believe but
you know
i have a hard time believing that i have
a hard time believing that yeah now and
and not not in a um
i have a hard time believing that
because i see it on
the
simplest terms on what happens with
family motives of family members
that seems motive of uh in companies
corporations you work with people you
look at the motive and you realize the
motive you thought was this and the
motive was that
i have a hard time seeing there's not
game gamesmanship taking place
uh here i just don't now do i think
the whole thing was started to get rid
of this guy versus the world is seen as
opera an opportunity here to get rid of
him maybe but why is the question
because you replace him who replaces him
who replaced the shock how many replace
the shot
anyways let's let's go
and once you do that yeah you're right i
mean it always opens up a problem but
look no putin again i'd go back to the
same thing he's been very clear about
what he wants to do and his incursion
into you know the eastern part of
ukraine uh years ago
what we're facing right now this full-on
invasion is just another step in his
process right it's not it's he he hasn't
gone off the rails he hasn't changed
this is just what he plans to do so
you'd have to go all the way back you'd
have to say okay let's go back you know
well before even 2014. let's if we're
going to go down that and say we're
doing this on purpose right where
somehow this was a conspiracy where
we're going to overthrow putin you got
to go back a lot further than just
what's happening right now to say yeah
this is all orchestrated i'm telling you
here the government
oftentimes you know they're not
organized enough to you know put
together panic and a doomed submarine
it's just not gonna happen right so
they
you know sometimes we give the
government a lot of credit right yeah
and i'm not saying they don't you know
things haven't happened that you know
we're wrong and shouldn't you know you
look at uh mk ultra's on the list that's
a good example of something that goes
way off the rails but look
here's here's here's a
human nature yeah and i may be wrong and
guys challenge me as much as you want
and
say you're absolutely wrong here i think
everybody in this room
and everybody we mostly meet
has selfish desires okay
you're here you'd like to promote the
show because that's what you're supposed
to do right
we're here sharing our opinions creating
content
if the audience they like it they
support us we appreciate it without them
we don't have we don't have a business
model there's not a podcast
uh so but if we also don't uh keep
staying entertaining then the market's
gonna say hey listen you guys are not
really good podcast stuff get out of
here do whatever else you want to do on
sell insurance or maybe go sell some gym
memberships right okay
so so adam has a motivation adam is
wanting to build his brand okay so he
wants to also get eyeballs because he's
wants to grow his podcast which has been
crushing it lately if you think i'm here
to promote the saucecast since it goes
live every thursday at 4pm and we have
amazing guests and beautiful women and
great controversy you're dead wrong
i would not promote the size of this
channel i apologize this is about the
pbd podcast not the sas you know what
then again it's thursday at 4pm go live
i would never do that uh so you know
what mike forgive me forgive me for
doing that my apologies but but here's
where i'm at but here's where i'm at
the where it goes to me is the following
i think almost everybody is
50 plus percent is them
50 plus percent is your motivation for
what your desires are what your needs
are right
some people are 60 them 40 others some
people are 70 some people are 80 you get
the idea yeah yeah if you get to the 80
mark or higher now it's more about you
people eventually are like you know what
dude you're a one-man show nobody can do
anything with you it's all about you
you're not a team person you're a
one-man show right
politicians and statesmen those are two
different things
politicians want to get reelected
politicians owe favors to people that
funded their campaign that you and i
don't know about politicians oh favors
to other people that said if i get you
elected dot dot dot so for me to sit
here and think and say you guys give the
politicians way too much credit i don't
give the politicians a lot of credit i
give the people that did favors for them
a lot of credit to come and collect
their debt that's who i give a lot of
credit because those guys are not
dummies i guarantee you lobbies are not
dummies i guarantee these money people
are not dummies last time we had a
dinner
at a restaurant we've never been to
calcasa d'angelo for the first time
we're there like three for the first
time
actually i've been there two nights and
we're going again by the way just so you
know we're taking a bunch of people but
we're casa de and the angel and we're
having dinner with this one private
equity guy right
you runs a multi-multi-billion dollar
fund this very well the whole team
showed up we had a great dinner together
conversation about you know what's going
on in media what's going on in business
anyway it's a great conversation that we
had with them but
i'm sitting across from the main guy and
i'm talking to what's his motive
to make returns what did
but the part that made it very
impressive
versus a guy that i met with last week
who crossed his arms and we offered to
have dinner with him and he said i don't
want to have dinner i just want to meet
you in the office where this guy
yesterday flies in is worth more than
the other guy
this guy flies and comes to my house
then we go to dinner spends five hours
with us and he says to me at the end of
the meeting would you mind if i take a
walk with your wife
and i said no prom we went over there i
took my baby they walked 20 30 minutes
they talked and then he says i just
learned a lot about you i'm so glad i
had a chance to talk to your wife
so to i know he still number one concern
is returning money for his investors
right but the fact that he wants to know
more about the dna of the individual
he's to me a 70 30 guy not a knight the
other guy was a 90 10 guy so
you're right i don't think these
politicians are
you know but i do think the people
behind closers are going to collect
their debt again that's where i'm at
yeah so yeah i'd say i see what you're
saying i don't i don't disagree i don't
disagree with that i'm just saying that
sometimes the nature of government is
that they can't um
you know i wouldn't give sometimes
and when i say government i'm not really
talking about politicians i suppose but
i wouldn't give them as much credit as
sometimes you know somebody like oliver
stone might worry says this is a massive
machination sometimes they fall into
[ __ ] right they fall into things and
then they think this is a happy
circumstance let's get let's let's do
this right i mean and but
um
yeah i know i but i agree i think what
you're talking about in part is
something i see it on a very you know
personal level where you see it a family
right you know do you have kids that are
empathetic right and you know to what
degree are they they have eq or whatever
they call it and so you know i got i got
three boys and then the uh the oldest
one scooter is it's very empathetic
right the middle kid doesn't give a [ __ ]
what you think yeah and so he's like
he's a completely different cat right
and the youngest one is just kind of a
happy-go-lucky kid but but uh you know
slugo he's like
you know i'm gonna tell you what i think
i don't care what you think about that
right and and so it's an interesting and
but so i look at it and you're right
people that's the way people work i do
agree 100 i've seen the lobbying
industry very close up in in washington
d.c
and yeah there's expectations right
there's there and part of it is how the
system's you know built now if you can
if you can send somebody to congress
or in the senate and they're there for
36 you know 42 years
that's from a lobbyist perspective
that's an investment to be made right
i'm going to invest in that person so
part of this and maybe i think about too
simplistically is you know get rid of
you know put in term limits and then
suddenly it's a little bit tougher to
say this is where i'm investing my money
meaning this particular politician who's
going to end up as a head of the ways
and means committee or whatever so now
if you've only got two terms and then
you got to get the hell out of there and
go back and do a job you know maybe as a
lobbyist now i got to rethink my
business right maybe i i ca i'm not
going to get those hooks in there yeah
if i if we were to make a list of the
top 10 enemies in america
that are hurting america the most i you
know i'm going to put lobbies in the top
10 list is where i would put them i
don't know where they rank as is if
they're going to be they're probably not
in the top five but they're in the top
ten levels lobbyists are hurting a lot
of things and they are great
great debt collectors
another question another question is the
following in regards to nixon you know
the whole story about the cia tried to
kill nixon many many years ago have you
followed that story or no uh not really
but i believe it had something to do
with elvis um so i'm just going to put
that out there i'm kidding yeah
did you see elvis is the new movie
that's coming out or no have you seen
the commercial no no is it another one
oh it's pretty sick you got to watch the
commercial yeah that's pretty sick yeah
he's coming out anyways he's playing
himself it's yeah
so if you don't know that story then i
want to skip that story that photograph
with elvis and nixon that's one of the
top
ironic photographs in american history
oh let's see this right badge given to
drug addled singer i mean
did you say did you see that movie i
think you'd do a very good job for the
united states of america well thank you
very much mr president that's actually
good tom that you do you do a good i was
in a good clinic
it gives him a badge there's a thing
where he gives him a badge remember that
yeah i can't wait to see this guy's
movie when it comes out there's a
trailer right there
let's watch something very important
here this this is very concerning for
adam uh in regards to declassified
government secrets shocking declassified
government secrets trained cat soldiers
okay
documents declassified in 1983 revealed
that the u.s government tested the idea
of training cats to be spies
implanting
recording equipment in their bodies and
letting them loose near the kremlin or
soviet embassy is this a true story it's
a true story
that's my
i'm here to tell you
that it was called acoustic kitty and uh
it was an operation and uh you know
where people can learn a lot about this
is on black files declassified which
appears every wednesday night there you
go
you're not selfish at all am i doing
this right exactly yeah um
discovery
channel yeah science channel science
challenge
discovery plus there's great things
about it i believe
yeah and uh so
the idea was um
yeah the idea was that look again uh if
you're trying to collect intelligence
you're gonna try to be creative the one
thing that one of the things that the
agency does well they've got a science
and technology directorate right that's
one of the
divisions in within the organization and
that's where incredible engineers work
and they've developed everything from
the u2 you know to the blackbird to
satellite you know technology uh battery
capability um and so
they do some amazing work down there and
one of the ideas was look if you know if
you're trying to collect on some target
in some you know country and um maybe
what you want to do is figure out a way
to get close to that target in an
unassuming way how about we implant um a
receiver
into a cat
i mean i know that sounds crazy but
these guys are just throwing ideas out
there they built a a
years ago they have decades ago they
built a thing called an except
insecticopter which was just a little
dragonfly that could hover and and you
know outside a window of say the soviet
embassy and uh collect uh intel um
it's it's incredible anyway the acoustic
kitty didn't work uh they also tried why
didn't it work um you know cats are as
it turns out are not that trainable
oh i know mike yeah there you go so it's
basically desertion right yeah yeah so
they as it turns out you know the cat i
base i i don't know i i don't have uh
all the insight but i think it spent
most of its time licking its own ass and
um those are more dogs yeah yeah well
let me ask you which created
interference and static on the little
you know the static phil the term for um
phil
what is it uh like international arms
dealers we've seen the movie war dogs
right yeah yeah sure and then in the
movies like he's a dog of war right yeah
how this cat idea
how much thought goes into it or
realistically how how like how often
does just someone just hide [ __ ] smoking
weed he's like man forget about war dog
war cats man that's where it's at yeah
well no that you think it is crazy right
because some of the [ __ ] that they came
up with was it was just remarkable um as
an example they built a a fish a remote
fish right because they were trying to
figure out what was going on at a
facility overseas somewhere and it had
an estuary right and so what they want
to do is collect water samples so
there's no way in hell they were going
to be able to accomplish this so anyway
they built this fish they have a copy or
one of them in the uh museum there at
headquarters it's incredible it's a fake
fish looks just like a damn fish and
this thing would they set it off and it
would swim up the you know estuary and
collect water samples and could you know
gather some other data and then come
back i mean so yeah they're throwing
ideas on the table but sometimes you
know it makes sense the again the
acoustic kitty didn't work they tried it
on a pigeon right and you know the the
gear was too heavy for the pigeon to
make it all the way
the target so but you never you know and
and you know some of the ones that
really work they don't they don't talk
but these are the kind of wacky ideas or
they're like let's put a budget together
let's put 20 million dollars into this
isn't there
a dolphin
yeah the dolphins are yeah look they
they they're very famous right
yeah and and look animals you know the
ones that could be trained you know
could you know could be used in this
this sense what they then went to what
this developed into was robotics right
and and uh and so the use of of uh you
know the insectothopter was a very
important development because while it
didn't necessarily work that well
because it wasn't as controllable as
they wanted it to be uh it allowed them
to
develop technology that could then be
used in other ways and so
you know anyway i'm banging on about the
all i can think about right now there he
is yeah all i can think about right now
is in the austin powers movie where he's
like sharks with lasers exactly
we're going to have sharks and put
lasers on them those laser beams scatter
okay
well let's let's talk about it let's
talk about so there's something happened
this last week that is deeply concerning
i'm wondering like as a
well-trained cia agent how would you
solve this mystery because
uh
it's it's it's heavy on my heart so an
alleged stoner
stopped after wild card chase whips out
license from legoland okay
a uk driver who was arrested for
reckless driving had officers and
stitches after producing
a license from legoland the driver was
pursued from bro bexley
to uh isle of a sheppy and arrested for
multitude of offenses last week
according to a tweet by kent police rpu
which apprehended the 21 year old
motorist in february following an epic
car chase
this was a 35 mile car chase and this
guy when he gets pulled over he takes
out his lego is this truly a real story
or what tell me you're joking with me
right no it's legit and you get the
license there's a driving lego land and
it's got like a speed cam
a few other things and you get this
license and here it is right here i've
seen i've actually seen this lego land i
took i took my daughter to that lego
land and that's true they you can get a
driver's license and yeah so the guy had
a big bag of weed
um
he's uh as far as i'm concerned he's a
hero um
i think it's a fantastic story and
great news right it does i think it says
more about the poor kent police because
the average highway patrol in any of the
50 states would be far less patient than
35 miles
you would have put you to put the trip
line down
pop the tires or catch up behind them
give them a spin
we just have you heard patrolling
doesn't let this happen have you ever
gone to the airport and you forgot your
idea or passport has that ever happened
to you
have you ever gone to the airport to
travel you forget yourself i feel like
you have a story behind it i'm just
curious because it's happened to me
multiple times i'm asking you if it's
happened to you
i'm sure it's never happened to you
actually it's never happened but it's
happened to you yeah i thought i showed
up and i realized all of a sudden i
didn't have a passport now to be fair i
was traveling to canada i guess i just
thought that was another state and so i
didn't think they'd actually want my
passport uh one time i went to the wrong
uh one time i went to the wrong airport
um i was heading back overseas
that this guy was right
now i was hungover uh i was i was back
in the states for just a few days got
together with some guys that were back
here this was when i was in the old job
and uh we went out and
might have had a little bit too much to
drink had to go overseas to do something
and uh went to uh instead of going to
dulles airport in washington i went to
national and you know
bounced around there for a while trying
to figure out where the hell's my flight
you know it's getting really shirty with
the the the gate people are saying no
but i'm playing i'm leaving here to go
and they said and they looked it up and
they go no you're supposed to be a
driver oh i love when yeah that's so
funny in dallas it would happen all the
time you're online the guy's like sir
your flight's from love field not from
dfw you're kidding me no you have to
leave okay
what happened to me one time is we
parked the car in dfw but morale booked
my flight back to love i totally forgot
about it and i'm like trying to go to
valley can you get my car i've been
waiting 20 minutes like sir we don't
have your car i'll call rob morrow's
like your car is a dfw
yeah but it's always a fun conversation
when you're saying i'm telling you i'm
patrick that david sir
whatever do you have an id no what would
you like me to show you and you have to
make phone calls to get that part done
uh let's talk about gas prices can you
pull up the picture somebody just sent
me from beverly hills so this was just
sent to me from beverly hills
and uh
gas prices in beverly hills 8 95
9
25 9
55
and a story comes out from common
dreams that i want to read to you on
page seven if you can pull up the other
stat that we had about where gas prices
went you remember the one that we did
the other day
i'm sure you have it if you don't i'll
send it to you as well
um 82 percent of u.s voters believe
inflation's fueled by corporations
jacking up prices released friday by the
advocacy group fight corporate
monopolies the polls showed that 82
registered voters blame
big companies for at least some of the
recent inflation spike and want elected
officials to take on powerful seals and
rate in corporate greed to lower prices
with
gas prices searching amid russia's
onslaught against ukraine against
ukraine democrats in the house and
senate introduced legislation that would
impose a windfall tax on oil companies
in an effort to curb profiteering last
year oil and gas companies made 174
billion dollars in profits bernie
sanders said
this year they're on track to make more
we cannot allow big oil companies to use
ukraine and inflation as an excuse to
rip off
americans what are your thoughts on that
yeah i think it's a lot more complex
going back to so
keeps going off is that yours tyler time
is that your ranked tone no someone's
goes up i don't [ __ ] it's mine okay so
it's yeah
i knew you were mistaken you were up to
something i know i know well
it's not easy getting signal into this
room um
but um
yeah you know i think it's it's
this this story is like so much else it
just it becomes a simple narrative right
and
if people took the time to say okay look
maybe i'm going to sit and study and
understand how the oil market works you
know maybe i
expand my thinking about this and just
think it's not that
exxon mobil is is screwing us over right
exxon mobil yeah
2021 they made what 20 23 billion
in 2020 they posted a 22 or 23 billion
loss right because of the pandemic so
and
oil prices
you know fluctuate based on world
conditions right so price is coming down
right now or why is it you know
why is it coming down well because in
part as as an example these discussions
are going on with iran and suddenly the
traders are thinking okay maybe we're
going to get that pipeline opened up
they're going to ease the sanctions so
yeah prices start to come down prices
may be fluctuating up because what
china's going through a lockdown again
right so what's that's going to do oh
[ __ ] now maybe we got a problem you know
with demand and supply
okay so i guess
do i think that the oil companies are
screwing us over um are they interested
in making profitable damn right they're
interested in making a profit but i
think that the the way that you know
one another problem here
the uh the biden administration
i think failed in in one way here with
with this energy issue
by not apparently
drawing a direct line between energy and
national security right energy is a
national security priority and so
therefore if you say that then you would
assume that in that case yes okay great
we should be a leader in green
technology that's a wonderful thing but
we should also be as
independent or close to independent as
possible in production of energy right
and so that's a national security
concern you we can do both
and in fact you know there aren't that
many people that invest as much money in
new green technologies as oil companies
because it's a profit motive for them
they understand right whoever builds the
next best battery is going to win so
yeah i i just think it's you know it's
more complicated than aoc or whoever
tweets about wants us to believe
hey david john can you guys show that
real quick gas prices for people to know
that gas prices have been climbing uh
way before putin invaded ukraine i think
it's important for audience to
constantly see this that it's been going
up since uh even november when the
election came out and they announced
look how low gas price they were two
dollars and it's gone up to 351 by then
that's nearly yeah 100 80 percent but go
ahead you were sorry i think this is a
perfect segue to a nice case example
from the biz dock right here not even so
much gas but how do prices work in the
market supply demand prices costs go up
i feel
gas aside how does it all work i'm sure
you have strong feelings on this well
when you look at fuel and everything
most people don't know there are
economists that work for the airlines
and they are some of the fastest and
best hedgers you're nodding mike on fuel
prices on the planet earth they are so
fast and so quick to hedge if you look
at any of the annual reports for um the
airlines they talk about their hedging
strategies their hedging staff and
everything and hedging means that they
see the prices change and they're trying
to actually keep the price of air
tickets balanced so that they can
maintain customer inflow they don't want
during spring break the price of a
ticket to double and they lose customers
they're trying to keep some stability
for summer travel and all these things
so they can go make a buck and the
second part of it is you're absolutely
correct we have in this country what
most people don't understand is the
strategic petroleum reserve and the
president can open and close the valve
to put oil that's in storage into the
market supply comes in the market prices
are moderated and he can do that and all
the things about drilling and everything
that takes a while okay you've got
permits you've got leases but i didn't
approve your permit right and so pasaki
will go to the microphone and say they
have leases up the wazoo and the guy
from fox nebach didn't get called on
he's like yeah but you didn't approve
the the actual permit to drill so if you
take a look at what everything's out
there if americans just understood two
things the president can ease prices
with the petroleum reserve number one
and number two it's good to be green but
balanced energy independence is even
better
most americans also don't know this
third point which is canada buys 100 of
its natural gas from the united states
of america we are actually a top four
energy exporter in the world and so
to blame the man you know it's just very
fashionable in an election year to go
blame the man oh big corporations are
screwing you again it's the man you know
you know you know one thing i got to
tell you tom you know people often tell
me i have an accent and they'll say pat
you got an axe i'm like oh okay cool i
got an accent i've never heard anybody
call
jen sackey jen pasaki and i love the way
you say putin you say putin it's like
such a unique canadian accent you have
that's wonderful can you go back to that
picture you showed by bumble what is it
called not uh who is
this due to gas prices next fast and
furious movie will be about that's oh my
god
but can you do me a favor and google
highest gas tax state just type in
highest gas tax state highest gas tax
state and look what comes out
uh okay so make it a little bit so
everybody can see it make it okay so
california new yorkers pay
66.62 cents on a gallon of gas the ninth
highest statewide
state gas tax alone is 48.22 cents a
gallon but california is 86.55
illinois is 78. pennsylvania is 77.
hawaii is 70. if you want to see the
next 10 click on it so the competitive
folks can see where they state ranks uh
make it bigger in pennsylvania hawaii
new jersey nevada indiana washington new
york michigan florida oregon north
carolina okay so these guys are saying
we need to ask these big corporations to
not uh you know as record-breaking
profits that they have fine if you're
really concerned
let's go through three different
organizations we hold you accountable
we hold the oil companies accountable
and we hold governors of states that are
charging a [ __ ] ton of taxes accountable
so if we do it that way then guess what
maybe there's a reasonable conversation
so one for 90 days if we're 100 of
canada gets their oil from us why don't
we start doing it ourselves for a time
period to lower gas gas prices number
two
talk to exxon and mobile and give them
some kind of a credit for the next
couple years to have a certain number
that they're doing to lower prices for
them and then contact all your governors
and tell them for the next six months
the gas tax that you're collecting right
now the 8655 we need to get rid of it
for the next 90 days to six months that
is a reasonable way where everybody is
pulling their own you know a startup
company when you get started and the
company is going through challenging
times the ceo will come in and they'll
do this they'll say guys let me tell you
where we are we all own equity in this
company yes yes okay
company is growing it's exploding but we
have a problem right now what's that our
margins are very small if we can make it
through the next 12 months we'll be fine
and our you know equity is going to be
worth a lot for but for the next six to
12 months
us the c-suite who can afford this
because we own the most uh what do you
call it we own the most shares in the
company i think we have to lead from the
front and do something with our salary
let me tell you what i'm doing my
million dollar salary i for the next 12
months i'm not taking a
penny
of salary i'm going to a penny
and i'm not telling you to do that as
well but all i'm telling you is see if
you can figure out a way
to take a lower salary the next 6-12
months so we can reinvest that money
into the company and then we can bring
it back up we need that for the next six
12 months but i'm telling you from front
my salary just went from a millionaire
to a penny for the next 12 months cfo
i've already had a conversation with
john john's already told me he's taking
a salary from a half a million to 120
and that's a savings on 380 per year
thank you cfo for doing that larry's
already agreed to go from 400 to 80
because he's also got savings larry
thank you for doing that then you go to
the rest of the parents [ __ ] okay i'm
willing to go to this oh great let's
open memorandum
then you go to your employees your
directors and your managers and you
present it to them then you go to your
partners your carriers your vendors
whoever it is then you say guys this is
what we're doing here's a memorandum we
would like you
to lower the expenses a little bit for
the next six 12 months work with us
we're growing very
this is the way you get people to say
you know what if you're gonna feel a
little bit of the pain i'm okay feeling
a little bit of pain i'm all in rather
than saying it's the corporations who
are doing
but you don't talk about your state you
don't talk about your own drilling you
don't talk about your own
responsibilities you just point it at
everybody else you become a hypocrite
that is the challenge i have with their
solution it's all this way but i'm not
held accountable to do anything again we
simply run a podcast we don't countries
we don't launch states but if somebody
came up like that and presented that to
me
i'd kind of say you know what uh okay
that's fair i'm listening
well it's also part of the problem is
also i think that
it's just
it's this idea that it's got to be all
or nothing right you're either all in on
on alternative you know sources of
energy
or you know you're you're a complete
[ __ ] and you know like you said a
balanced energy policy but that's got to
be driven from the top i really do think
that one of the reasons why we're
staring at this invasion in in ukraine
right now is because we we got our
energy policy so wrong right if oil if
crude's down at you know
bucks a barrel putin really can't afford
his
adventurism that he's engaged in right
now
you get it up to where it's been and
when it's been climbing too and that
gives him a lot of hope and then he
looks around and he thinks yeah you
fed into my plan anyway you know it's
been clear for years that he's using
energy as a weapon that's an obvious
statement right and we just fed into it
by you know saying we're just we're
putting our hands up you know what we're
going to kill the energy industry here
in the states you know in our pursuit
for for green technology
and he looks at that and he goes yeah
great that that's exactly what i want
and thank you for the help so yeah i
think we we screwed the pooch on that
one as far as the current administration
goes meanwhile meanwhile did you guys
hear about what saudi arabia announced
the last 24 hours have you have you seen
this or no tyler
okay so go to wall street journal story
or examiner or fox or bloomberg or any
one of them you can go to any one of
their stories okay
so saudi arabia just announced if you
can open that up
saudi arabia considering accepting the
the one instead of
dollars for chinese oil sales okay so
china is plain aggressively coming in
saying hey
we're here
we're waiting
um
can you imagine what happens if saudi
arabia goes away from the dollar which
the dollar has historically been what
the main currency and now they're gonna
take this angle what kind of a look is
that on u.s what kind of a look is that
on the administration what kind of a
look is that for the world what is the
world saying when they see this
oh oh
motive
china's officially
the new
powerhouse in charge u.s is getting more
and more and more weaker with the dollar
what do you think about when you see
this tom
man we got to get that vice president
out there to say something nonsensical
you know we got to send her on a tour no
i think this is this is also i think
national security the dollar's been a
storehouse of value and also the store
sort of the ruler by which all
currencies are measured it's been the
stable currency and it may be oh well
that's an elite thing to say such an
imperialist thing to say to put your
currency out there but i think it's a
security issue
personally
can you pull up the article to read the
whole article go to the wall street
journal one this is the hill is this is
this the other one's behind the paywall
okay let me look at this one two nations
have intermittently intermittently uh
discussed a major of a matter of six
years but talk seven twenty 2022
disgruntled over the united states
nuclear negotiations with iran and its
lack of backing for saudi arabia's
military operation and
boom
there you go by the way did you see what
just happened right there
these guys are sitting there negotiating
with iran okay
on nuclear deals and saudi says no
problem i thought we were your number
one ally you're doing that we're going
to china nearly 80 of global oil sales
are priced in dollars and since the mid
70s
the saudis have exclusively used the
dollar for oil training as part of
security agreement with the u.s
government according to the journal the
talks are the latest in an ongoing
effort for beijing both to make its
currency threat tradable in
international oil markets and strengthen
its relationship with the saudis
specifically china previously aided
riyadh uh in construction of ballistic
missiles and construction nuclear power
conservation relations has increasing
fate in recent years crown prince
mohammed bin salah solomon uh initially
put forth a public image as a reformer
liberalizing liber liberalizing the
country's policies on women righteous
however 2017. anyway so there you go you
sit there and you negotiate with iran
you lose saudi well but the interesting
thing with china is while china's been
uh increasing their their military
support and uh technology uh cooperation
with uh the saudis they've also been at
the same time and are currently iran
yeah increasing their economic uh you
know uh cooperation with iran which if
you look at it if they go how do you
square those they don't care that's
china as long as it's in the xi's
regime's best interests that's all they
care about they are very straightforward
it's what you said before about you know
your enemies and at least honestly yeah
you know china how many billion did
china get 400 billion 25 years exactly
is am i saying it correctly 400 billion
25 type in iran china 400 billion 25
years well isn't aren't they kind of
talking out both sides of their mouth
right there whereas
i'm talking about saudi arabia right
here so search it search it tyler just
type in china iran they're acknowledging
the fact that china is doing business
with iran investing in iran but now
they're they're basically
dissing america because we're having
conversation with iran it's not like
we're having
um economic conversations with iran
we're trying to basically figure out
this iran nuclear deal that's went back
and forth left and right for 10 years
now but we the the the the current
administration is very clear about the
you know their essential their agreement
to lift sanctions right so that that
opens the spigot and gets the iranian
oil flowing that concerns the saudis so
they're going to look at that in terms
of their own interests um no it's it's
it is that and china again you look at
it just their relationship with putin
and putin is it is it
i like that uh you look at their
relationship and again china you know
do you honestly think that they're going
to respond to you know threats where the
u.s may say well you know if you better
not cozy up or cooperate with uh putin
because uh you know that's not gonna end
well for you we're gonna you know impose
sanctions that's not how she's gonna
respond right g is is dealing with uh
russia right now because he perceives it
as in his best interest
as soon as this thing if it were to go
really ugly you know you're going to see
daylight between them because china's
playing a much longer game and i just so
it is fascinating but this this uh this
conflict apparent conflict between them
dealing with both the saudis and iran at
the same time is i think has been
fascinating well hold on i just thought
of something this is a perfect analogy
to what you were talking about
you talked about i trust my enemies more
than i trust my allies
well we know that iran is our enemy
facts okay
what the [ __ ] is saudi arabia at this
point to us
are they our ally are they our strategic
partner are they an enemy did they have
an involvement in 911
that is what's clouding u.s judgment
right there is i don't know what to make
of saudi arabia saudi arabia
is michael jordan when he says
republicans and democrats buy jordans
everyone buys oil everyone buys oil
so they stay in the middle and they just
say hey listen china buys from us russia
buys from us iran by not maybe not iran
but u.s buys from us everybody buys
friends that's their perspective on us
what should our perspective be on saudi
arabia you buy from them saudi arabia
that's just it's a business
very good question it's not a vendor
it's a partner what is the difference
between a vendor and a partner vendor
you use once in a while a partner you
use all the time you can't treat saudi
arabia as a vendor us is treating them
as a vendor it's an insult the way
you're handling them as a vendor i would
also be upset if i'm them you need to
treat them as a partner they're not
trying to attack you they're not trying
to do anything to you what do you mean
how many people from 911 were from saudi
arabia the saudi the saudi the saudi
government that's selling oil to you
yeah you need to treat them as an as a
partner not a vendor you can't just go
to him and say you're now an enemy do
that so let's just say you do that since
1973 they've been using u.s dollar and
now they're going to go to china now
what happens i totally understand what
you're saying obviously we want to keep
them on the dollar and be a partner but
you're pointing out
something that
you know this administration previous
administrations it's a very difficult
relationship it's in it because we're
but you know people are very conflicted
about it but i agree with the fact that
the world is the way it is you got to do
business with what you got sometimes
you're dealing with with a government
that you look at and go in an ideal
world you're not what we'd like to deal
with of course but [ __ ] it that's not
the way that serves two evils and then
how do you even
talk to your partner about clearly
mbs muhammad bel salman
chopped up
uh the
journalists
clearly that happened
okay on the world stage everyone
condemned that
all right well you know sorry about
khashoggi let's just get some more oil
going like where the lines are so
blurred with saudi arabia yeah and
that's what makes me bring what do you
do so that's the question that's why we
got cia here yeah but what do you do in
this situation you would you rather
do you see more
uh saudi arabia having an honest
relationship with you or iran
i i well again do you trust your enemies
you know that they hate you or do you
trust your your supposed partner ally
what what are we buying from iran
nothing we're buying we're buying their
ability to not uh create nuclear
capabilities we're buying them off okay
but by doing that you're also pissing
off saudi correct and that's the whole
sunni shiite dilemma you know how you do
you have anybody in your family that no
matter or friends
no or employees or any customers
no matter what you do you can never make
them happy yes okay i've had people like
you know what i when i when i finally
get to a point that i'm like there is
nothing i can do to make her happy make
him happy make them happy nothing listen
guys let's just go our separate ways
because
there's no
hey let's take them out to them
oh everything goes good next day put you
guys hey let me get them to ski hey let
me do so you're you're never going to
make iran happy but at least you can
keep saudi civil so which one do you
want to look at more as a long-term
person you want to keep
how do you handle the nuclear
negotiations with iran do you just do
you
have to ask the question even if the
guidelines you put in place do you trust
they're going to follow the agreement
seriously like you think she follows
foreign relation policies seriously
right i mean we had that agreement
between xi and and president obama at
one point today okay we're not going to
engage in cyber shenanigans well that
that's a lot of horseshit or we're not
going to engage in economic espionage of
course they are that's how they got to
the you know the the point on the food
chain where they're at right now that's
how they intend to get to the top but i
think with saudi and every other nation
you've got to think from terms of we're
going to act in our own national best
interests what is
important for our national security
what's in our best interests as a nation
that's how every other country does
nothing wrong with that well well we
tend to apologize for it
on occasion um
which is puzzling you're talking about
the obama apology tour around the mid uh
middle east yeah well and and just in
general every time we we act in our own
best interests it's like oh my god i
can't believe we're doing that and you
or you'll get it out in social media and
that sector of the population will be
angst written but um yeah i think with
with with the with the iran nuke uh deal
look how do you how do you deal with
that well you you deal with it by
getting a better deal than we had right
we didn't have full transparency yeah
because they wouldn't allow it so when
john kerry would bang on about trust and
you know verification yeah well we
couldn't verify because we didn't have
access to some of their key facilities
right and that's a problem so create a
better deal or just say fine we're not
gonna i'm sorry we're like we're not
getting that deal and yes we're gonna
then have to have better intelligence
that's gonna
allow us right now
our intelligence on that target is kind
of all over the place right you know
some people say well you know their
breakout is you know a month away yeah
maybe the breakouts 12 months away well
that's there's a big gap there right so
that's that's an important part of this
because at some point maybe the decision
is you got to go in and degrade what
they're doing
um but
yeah you you talk about the saudis
that's a you hear that all the time in
washington people are always spin spun
up about this you know sounds like we
got to get some cats on the scene in
iran there's snoop around yeah nuclear
cats
you know dogs
do you guys see the homer story with joe
rogan did you see that story homer gets
canceled meets joe rogan a new simpsons
episode this is a new york post story
the simpsons
as dividing critics after spoofing
controversial podcast host joe rogan 54
in a brand new episode
satirizing
cancer culture in the divisive season 33
episode 14 titled you won't believe what
this episode is about act 3 will shock
you homer
is erroneously blamed for leaving the
family dog named santa little helper
in a hot car resulting in him getting
publicly shamed newsweek reported things
really go off the rails when the
simpsons uh patriarch tries to apologize
and inadvertently knocks reverend
lovejoy out of the church window videos
of the fiasco subsequently go viral on
social media causing homer to lose his
job and become ostracized by his family
and friends co-workers eventually the
donut gobbler meets up with joe rogan
paul ganger the commentators never
explicitly mentioned by name but he is
represented by a generic right-wing
podcast host
who is the only one willing to meet with
homer following his cancellation
needless to say the gap rank hollow with
many critics with screen rant deeming
it's bizarrely misguided and
self-contradictory particularly
problematic per side with the fact that
homer was under
uh undeserving of his ex-communication
presumably unlikely many so-called
victims of cancer culture so
what do you think about this by the way
does that even look like joe rogan does
he look like kind of joe a little bit
yeah i like how they just said we're not
going to name them right wink [ __ ] okay
right
pariah's welcome
how shall we draw him let's draw him
like this and we won't name him
yeah yeah the the other day they uh uh
they called russell brand a right wing
podcast can you imagine calling russell
brand right wing republican podcast but
apparently now joe rogan is a couple of
the guys share the video was true it
went viral on on twitter
about the times joe
has said things that has nothing to do
with being right-wing the only thing
he's doing is he's questioning things
right i think he said one time you know
barack obama's the best president of our
generation yeah right-wing guy would
never say that they would probably say
something he would vote for bernie he
would vote for bernie he said a bunch of
different things but uh such [ __ ]
how they portray him as being right-wing
just because he says things that are
contradictory to the narrative that is
being spoken out there it's absolutely
true look he's he
he just has interesting people on and
you know
asks questions good questions you've
been on rogan how many times yeah a
dozen or so just a dozen times
no big deal mike baker
yeah yeah but it's it's he's he's just
he's just curious he's curious about
everything right but god forbid you
should you know
have someone say something on your show
that somebody else doesn't agree with
the one thing about self-righteous
people is i don't know how they
they're so [ __ ] dry they have there's
no sense of humor right i mean who the
[ __ ] takes exception to a simpsons
episode i mean how does that work so
anyway meanwhile meanwhile joe keeps
winning
because all this you do you're all just
helping them win
the mainstream media doesn't even know
it they're officially joe rogan's best
publicist and the great news is he has
to pay them
nothing they're doing it for free
oh by the way all this publicity they're
doing do you realize
if you if you were to put a dollar
amount
of how much the media's [ __ ] talking of
him making videos saying stuff how many
billions of views it got joe and if you
were to put a dollar amount on it i'm
gonna speculate on what that dollar
amount is if joe was running for office
and he wanted to buy this viewership
it's probably going to cost him 300
million dollars so mainstream media just
brought joe rogan 300 million dollars of
free publicity by the way joe needs to
say thank you to my favorite
this is not this is not new the same
thing happened with rush limbaugh you
may remember that there is a small
coterie of democrat congressman that
tried to pass what they called the hush
rush act
and he was talking about equal time and
that led rush on this big campaign where
it was i am equal time and it actually
propelled rush from the consortium of am
talk into the whole eib network and so
it actually was jet fuel on russia's
trajectory and we see it again 20 years
later yep and by the way
all the news of rogan getting canceled
you don't hear that as much anymore
right this reminds me of kind of what
jordan peterson said he was sitting in
mike baker's seat right there he said
listen the hardest part to do
is
deal with it when it's at its worst when
things are the heat is on you if you
could stick it out
you'll be sitting pretty on the other
side now
you know everything that happened with
our friends at spotify and
um rumble offering him a hundred million
bucks yeah where's that now yeah i think
he'll survive the worst of it neil young
put himself back on spotify as it turns
yeah he went back and as did i think
everyone else i'd love to see the neil
young on joe rogan podcast coming soon
oh by the way that would be that would
be
about you yeah
yeah if there's a guy that could pull it
off he could pull it off to to do
something like that in regards to you
know getting somebody and by the way did
you guys hear about the putin's
girlfriend have you guys heard about
putin's girlfriend or no do you hear
anything
can you pull this up so
inside the luxury life of putin's secret
girlfriend as ukraine goes through hell
okay this is a mirror story tyler i
don't know where you found this from her
name is alina i believe right yeah i
noticed you had a picture of her on your
computer i don't know why
the olympic gold medal medal winning
gymnast alina caballeva 38 reportedly
traveled to very private and very secure
chalet near lugano in switzerland with
her young children while russia invaded
ukraine widely believed to be the mother
of putin's two sons and a daughter or
possibly two daughters
cabeva lives in a luxurious uh bubble
shielded from the horse
her 69 year old partner is inflicting on
instant children in february 2015 the
local tv station reported that cabeza
had given birth at a private vip
maternity clinic in sorengo on the
periphery of the city in spotless clean
streets that weave between cartier gucci
louis vuitton mega rich russian strolls
through pampered pooches anyways was
that her in the previous picture too go
back she's a gymnast yes she's very
flexible she is quote the most flexible
woman in russia well
it's true that opposites are trash she's
uh she's very flexible and and putin not
too flexible on his thoughts and
opinions is this true
for the rest of us this is a kgb torture
move but yeah
yeah you could uh put a listening device
in here
and be like acoustic kitty here we go
this is just one to come see where i'm
going with yeah yeah yeah very creative
yeah and you say ci is not that creative
what are you talking about i know
they're very naturally creative did you
guys hear about this um
uh the race that congress gave
themselves did you see the race it's
very honorable so if you want to go to
this page five
uh congress decides to give them a raise
i think it's on page six okay congress
gives themselves a double digit race
this is a town hall story amid economic
turmoil for the american people their
representative in washington gave their
office double-digit raise this month
even as the average american worker
finds their real wages decreasing due to
inflation that outpaces wages at new if
you missed congress given itself a
little pat on the back
that's understandable members aren't
likely to tout outside the beltway how
they're filing their own uh filling
their own
office coffers plus the funding increase
for congressional offices just went uh
was just one part of the 2700 page
omnibus build that funded the us
government into a one and a half
trillion dollars the roll call explains
5.9 billion dollar fiscal 2022
legislative branch
funding the increased taxpayer funding
for congressional offices is 134 million
dollars more than was allocated in the
last fiscal year a
21
increase according to the house
appropriations committee summary in
addition congressional offices in the
house side get 18.2 million dollars in
paid internships that 21 21 raise for
the offices with a 5.1 percent
year-over-year wage growth for household
reporting of february's job report and
you can see why americans might not be
that thrilled and frustrated that's why
i asked tyler to ask to check how much
the military got a raise in the last uh
12 months 2.7 percent raise so they get
a 2.7 race and they gave themselves a 21
race gotta love it i mean this is a very
honorable move for them
inflation is about eight percent timing
yeah
you gotta think you know with all the
bipartisanship that's going on in
congress finally there's something they
agree upon let's give ourselves more
money anyone object mcconnell pelosi all
right let let's do it all right get more
money term limits term limits term
limits that's this i mean it is
astounding when you look at the size of
of of of the operation of congress and
the number of staffers they've got um
god i can't say enough bad things
they're so dysfunctional that's the
other part of it is and we we're clearly
not sending our best and brightest to
washington i mean i think
possibly most people would hopefully
agree on that
but the system is designed to it seems
like increasingly send
dysfunctional people to washington was
they say every now and then an innocent
man is sent to the legislature
by the way i want to just get a quick
look at congressional approval ratings
and where they stand
right now tyler's on the scene
where do they stand tyler i think it
just said 18
all right
i'm curious like what other things
should we look at for uh raises that are
given so military being one of them uh
old old folks retirements they're
getting what social security check to
see how much social security raises they
didn't increase it okay if it matches it
i respect it if you if you increase
social security
so if your social security is what uh uh
are there net socialists getting banned
while inflation is what seven point nine
percent and you're raising a five point
nine percent but congress got 21 percent
it's not uh
not again but these are the types of
things that the average person watches
and says let me get this straight
we're going through [ __ ] yeah you're
raising gas prices
i'm going through what i'm going through
right now during this time you secretly
all give yourself a 21 raise but you
don't do it to me so if this were to
happen and they raised social security
by 21
they raised military by 21
they raised themselves by 21 then
somebody could say what okay cool i can
see that fine even though the number may
be astronomically high
uh but when you do it and you give
yourself 21. social security 5.9
military 2.7 right it's it's what mike
baker would call it an [ __ ] move
yeah
by the way
the medicare surcharge is coming so
the six percent they gave you they then
take away on drugs hospitalization and
physicians so it's probably not less for
grandma not to mention the inflation
rate of eight percent um you know eating
into that as well on grandma's groceries
and if you want to read more about this
you can check out the 2700 page uh bill
that's uh reaching congress right now
which nobody read zero they passed it
again how how
screwed up do you have to be to put
together a 2 700 page omnibus bill
not allow for people to debate it read
it
create some transparency around it for
the voters
and then make a decision and this is but
they do this [ __ ] all the time and i
guarantee the people that wrote those
most of that legislation
they're like 23 year old interns and
staffers you know who you know are
probably hungover uh i'm not i'm not
saying that's a bad thing at sounds like
when you get at the atm
yeah
so we've
looked into the camera remember we'll
find out when we pass it remember that
yeah she looked right into the camera so
that was for the one
the infrastructure deal or the yeah yeah
okay
we'll find out when we pass it so we had
a ton of good comments today and i want
to get one in and since we have mr black
files declassified right i thought this
was really interesting
uh ronan returns asks he asked a few
things but specifically
if there was alien contact who would
have jurisdiction i think that's so it
would it be the president would it be
the head of the military the atf
they would they would have they show up
with cigars
why can't they land in manhattan
i gotta ask you yeah i figured you a cia
guy is coming in here you could be you
could have a double life as a comedian
you could have pretended you were
comedian do most yeah guys have this
sense of humor or you're like the funny
guy in the crew that's the only skill
set i had when they recruited me was
that i i did like uh four years
undercover as a as a stand-up um and
traveled around the world because you
get a good access right and so no you
know what most of the guys i know are
a lot funnier and smarter than i am um
so funnier i find it hard to believe
let's get him to answer the question
because this guy wants to know the
question so what do we do with these
aliens
well you know what um if you if you set
aside area 51 which is pretty much where
we keep them all uh
it's it it's a good question because who
would have jurisdiction over an airline
i don't i hope to god
what's the guy's name ronan ronan i
don't have a [ __ ] clue
oh come on yeah and if you did you
wouldn't say okay well that's fair
enough yeah to say to say that look they
would the cia have jurisdiction well
possibly because you know it involves a
foreign asset i think you could say that
um you know the bureau would probably
come in and say it's our turf across the
state lines yeah so you probably you'd
probably get this sort of thing going on
but look area 51 you know going to that
that was set up by you know uh by the
agency basically but it was set up for
the development of uh air assets of you
know of new technology and so that's you
know again whether it's the blackbird or
whether you're talking about u2 or
any of our uh
assets it's
so area 51 was started
and and it made sense right
that people would be going what the [ __ ]
is that i saw something really bizarre
flying around well yeah you know you
just saw a stealth wing you know fly
over your your ranch and it looks like
an alien aircraft so
i mean i get why area 51 is so
fascinating and it is fascinating but um
i think if if we and actually
encountered and and there are some
things going on right now uh the
pentagon came out and and
actually admitted that they had an
office a tip that was following you know
unidentified aerial phenomena and trying
to figure out what the hell they were
that was a big admission by the pentagon
so then you ask yourself well why did
they come out and say that what what
were they just trying to get ahead of
something or were they just thinking
okay it's you know it's time we can
declassify the fact that this office
existed
um so but that it from a national
security perspective if you've got
something out there that uh say a naval
aviator saw and couldn't identify and
you've got gun camera footage of it then
it makes sense from a national security
perspective you better be investigating
and figuring out what it is is it a you
know new technology from a hostile
nation or what the hell it is so well
you first of all you know that's uh
interesting question to ask gabby
curicino myself on what the answer to
that question it's going to be joe rogan
we're just gonna
yeah so but we we are coming to the end
of the podcast and a reminder to
everybody season two of black files
declassified airing wednesday nine p.m
eastern standard time on science channel
and discovery plus we have a commercial
to show you with this that's coming up
if you want to play that nice uh here we
go
why was our government investigating the
paranormal that information is still all
classified to this day
whatever was being done was done for
mind control
you fully immerse yourself in the enemy
this was by far the most terrifying
experience of my life
it might be something right here
it seems like an effort to keep the
public in the dark that's exactly how
psychological operations work hello
i wouldn't call this a treatment i would
call it torture the soviet union created
a doomsday system
these systems are always learning
they're always developing is that an
existential threat to mankind the navy
is already looking at how to use aerial
drones to attack an objective whoever
can master those techniques that will
rule the world
there we go next wednesday 9 p.m black
files be classified do not miss it put
the link below to get more information
on that mike thank you brother thank you
of course great to have you on really
enjoyed it i'm glad we had a chance to
do it face to face looking forward to
the next time we have you on again i
would look forward to that very much
thank you thank you mike guys take care
we'll do this again uh tyler next week
right nothing this week okay we'll do it
again next week have a great weekend
everybody bye bye bye bye
you